It's great to welcome back to the program
today. Brian Class, who is an assistant professor
of global politics at University College London,
a columnist.
It's for the Washington Post and also host
of the new podcast series. Power corrupts.
Brian, great to talk to you again. Thanks
from on. So let's talk a little bit about
the Trump administration and geopolitics.
If folks follow you on Twitter, they know
that you have no shortage of specific and
pointed critiques of how the current president
has been managing a variety of different geopolitical
relationships and and, and sort of day to
day issues. If you were to sort of zoom out
a little bit, how do you sum up the Trump
administration in terms of its relationship
to geopolitics and other countries?
That's a great question. So I think there's,
there's two main things that I've focused
on. Um, the first one is how Trump has changed
our politics towards authoritarian leaders
and human rights. And the second is how he's
been a chaos agent with just about everything
else. So to start at the first one, you know,
there is not been really many dictators or
desk spots that Trump is not fighting over,
right? The one exception of this is Nicolas
Maduro in Venezuela. But other than that,
Trump has cozied up to every single authoritarian
he's encountered writing me. He said that
he's fallen in love with Kim Jong Un and he's
praised president Jews become presidents of
life effectively in China. He's praised President
Ertel on who's dismantled democracy in Turkey.
He has praised President Duterte, who's committed
thousands of attributional killings in the
Philippines. You know, he has no shortage
of love for, uh, you know, LCC in Egypt, you
name it.
There is a Trump tweet or some sort of comment
praising these dictators and best spots around
the world. And the point that I've tried to
really make, which I think is underappreciated
in US foreign policy circles, is that everybody
outside of Egypt, the Philippines, Turkey,
China, what have you, every, every other country
in the world is paying attention to this.
So when I've done research in say, Southeast
Asia or sub Saharan Africa, they're taking
cues from what they can get away with, from
what the u s presidents says is acceptable
and what might actually have consequences.
And so my real worry is that this rise of
authoritarianism that we've seen over the
last 12 years, we're where the state of democracy
is declined globally every year for 12 years.
It's accelerating, it's getting worse, and
then we're going to live in a much more dangerous
world. The more authoritarian it can come.
So that's one big part of Trump's foreign
policy that I object to. The second, and I'll
be more concise with this, is the chaos agent
aspect of this where Trump behaves in a way
where he doesn't really care about the consequences.
He just does stuff and sees what sticks, right?
And, and it has consequences that are very
predictable. So with the unilateral withdrawal
from the Iran agreement, for example, it is
no surprise that now there is a crisis and
international crisis that's spiraling out
of control around the Strait of Hormuz in
Iran. It was predictable. We knew this was
going to happen last, uh, last year when he
pulled out in the agreements, every expert
said this will have a ratcheting effect, an
escalating effect. And now here it is, right?
I mean the trade war with China, extremely
predictable consequences with geopolitical
risk baked in now. And so whenever issue he
touches is very cursory knowledge to put it
charitably of geopolitics and his sort of
offhanded tweets have real world consequences.
The problem I think is that they take a while
to manifest and so we haven't seen the catastrophic
risk that he's creating come home to roost
quite yet, but I suspect we will in the coming
year and that the destabilization is going
to get much, much worse in 2020.
Well this relates to to two topics I've been
talking about a lot. One is the shift of the
Overton window to the right. And the other
is, and not even to the right, it's more of
a, it's really towards authoritarianism actually
as you pointing out and the creeping normalization
of how we expect a president of the United
States to behave and act. And the example
I gave is if on day one of the presidency
Trump wanted to debate caging, immigrant children,
it would have been too much too quickly. And
so you really like the two and a half years
where you slowly, slowly pushed the conversation
and then it's like, well, do they deserve
soap or don't they that they, they deserve
soap. And that's why I feel like you, you
know, think things moved slowly, even in a
four year term. The dynamics of the first
half of the term in the second half of the
term can be quite different. And that's the
danger that I think causes a lot of people
not to realize how things have shifted.
Yeah, I mean the analogy that I've used in
the past is that we're in scandal overload.
Right? And that's, that's actually a huge
gift to opening the Overton window because
you can't really keep track of all the scandals
at once. You can't keep track of all the ways
he's busting norms and violating American
values because they're happening so routinely.
And the analogy I use is we're like a golden
retriever and exploding tennis ball factory,
right? But you, you, you, you catch one tennis
ball in your mouth for a minute and then another
one comes along and you chase that for a minute
and then another one comes along and in, in
the process you lose fat. You lose sight of
the fact that the whole factory is exploding.
Right? And so I think this is, this is exactly
what's happened over the last couple of years,
is the unthinkable has become routine and
that as we continue to accept new normal's
dangerous normals as routine occurrences,
it gives the encouragements of Trump to simply
behave that way because he gets away with
it.
Right. And I think this is something that
scares me about a second Trump term, is that
it's the ultimate acceptance, right? It's
the ultimate sort of endorsement that what
has just happened for the previous few years
is acceptable, retain normal, and we'll let
it happen again. And if that happens, if he
gets another term and he gets the endorsement
of the American public in, you know, even
if it's a contentious election, they'll still
take it as a mandate. I think the Overton
window will expand much more in that second
term than in the first term. But that's why
I'm very, very worried about what that would
look like for American bottom. See foreign
policy and the way our system of government
functions.
So to play devil's advocate, or really what
I call stupid devil's advocate, because a
lot of these questions don't, don't, I think
really have to be considered as seriously
as as maybe some would. You've talked about
a lot of the ways in which other countries
are receiving signals from Trump about what
can they get away with and they are sort of
modifying their behavior as such. What about
the argument that within the United States
there has not really been any deleterious
effect along these lines as a result of Trump
cozying up to these authoritarians worldwide.
And maybe in fact it's gaining Trump, I dunno
to play like really dumb devil's advocate,
some kind of new found respect from some portions
of the amount of American electorate or something.
Right? Like fill it in with whatever argument
you want. What about the impact within the
United States?
Yeah, I mean, so the thing is that when you
have foreign policy change over time, you
know, in places that most Americans don't
think about on a daily basis. Yeah. The average
person doesn't feel that effect. Right. But
the fact that the u s for a series of decades
had cozied up to, for example, dictators in
North Africa and the Middle East came home
to roost when the Arab spring happened. And
if people don't think that's affected them,
I mean the amount of, we had an intervention
of Olivia, we had the destabilization in the
Middle East completely. We had the refugee
crisis, which has prompted a rise of far right
politics in the UK, in the UK, the EU, the
u s we have Brexit partly fueled by that collapse
and the refugee problem that it created. And
so, you know, all these things take time to
manifest, but when the world becomes more
authoritarian, it becomes more dangerous.
You know, democracies are our, our stable
partners, they're stable allies. They're people
you can work with and trade with that don't
fundamentally collapse in the same way that
when a dictatorship falls, it implodes in
very dangerous ways that destabilize the region,
all this stuff. So, you know, to me the aspects
of endorsing authoritarianism may not be felt
in, you know, July or August, 2019 it's totally
possible. And that's why Trump might get away
with it for quite awhile longer, but the world
has become going to become much darker, not
just for the people who are likely to face
much more egregious human rights violations
from autocrats empowered, but also from the
eventual fallout when those regimes collapsed,
as they always do. And it might happen as
I say in years, it might happen in even a
decade, but you know like Trump's modus operandi
with business where he would stiff people
and stick them with the bill or you know,
just simply not pay it. He might leave office
with us to pay the bill of his authoritarian
style foreign policy and I think that is going
to be something that will define American
interest down the road. Even if people say
on the American heartland, don't realize it
right now.
Well that's exactly the next thing I wanted
to talk about, which is early on in his presidency
there were a lot of sort of slightly symbolic
executive orders or executive orders directing
a department to do a, B or c but not really
being a significant change to policy. Then
you started getting into some directives that
did sort of connect to a policy change, but
they could be pretty quickly undone like as
soon as the next president is in who has a
different idea, they can reverse some of those
decisions relatively quickly. Is it the foreign
policy, geopolitical stuff that is going to
be of the most lasting impact and most difficult
to quickly undo. And I'm talking about things
like the tariff program with China with no
clear off ramp, uh, moving the u s embassy
in Israel to Jerusalem. Like pick whichever
ones you want, but are those the most longterm
to undo areas of the presidency?
Yeah, so I think, I think yes and no. I mean
I'm on the foreign policy aspects of this.
What Trump is sending emotion is difficult
to undo because longterm strategic orientation
stuff, right? The trade war with China, you
can't just undo that on day one. Even if you
get rid of the tariffs, China is going to
think about the u s differently. You know,
US trade policy will be fundamentally transformed.
I think the thing that's really going to be
difficult to undo for a Democratic president
say that if they win in 2020 is the credibility
aspect, right? Because you have holes in places
like Germany, a historic US ally, where the
German public now views the u s and Russia
as equal threats. Right? I mean that's just
unbelievable. And eventually that is going
to shift German politics to actually make
strategic changes to how they think about
the United States.
The same as happening here in the UK where
people are thinking less about the United
States as a benevolent ally and Morris something
you're the hedge your bets against because
they're not reliable, they can't be trusted,
et Cetera. And so I think that is going to
be very, very difficult to change. But I do
think the domestic stuff is going to be really
difficult to reverse course on for particularly
something you talked about before, the Overton
window and the decline of norms in US politics.
I mean once the genie is out of the bottle
and how the president behaves by bashing the
press, scapegoating minorities telling constant
lies, violating ethics rules, you know, hiring
cronies and family members in the higher office.
How do you, how do you just go back to the
old system? I mean, I think there is a series
of huge percentage of the electorate, you
know, whether it's 35 or 45% of the electorate
isn't just okay with this stuff.
They cheer for it, they want it. And so my
worry is that you're going to have the loss
of confidence in the United States from people
abroad and particularly our allies at the
same time that the Republican Party may be
permanently transformed into one that uses
Trumpism as its rally cry. And that is a very
difficult problem to undo even if you have
a well intention Republican candidate in 2020
or God help us 2020 for a, I'm sorry, I'm
sorry. But you know, the Republican candidate
that comes out in 2024 after Trump news, hopefully.
Yeah. Um, that would be something where the
damage is going to take, I think, much more
than one election cycle to repair, probably
more like decades. And I know that's depressing
to hear, but I think it's also true and it's
certainly something that I'm hearing on this
side of the Atlantic by people who think about
the United States very differently from the
Obama years.
Yeah. I mean, not that this is in any way
analogous, but in, I was born in Argentina
and after many years of one of the most corrupt
presidents in a very long time, Christina
Kirschner, a president who is like a center,
right? Guy Markety was able to win even with
support from people who would not typically
vote for a center rightist because of the
sort of positioning as I'm going to stop the
corruption, I'm going to stop the cronyism.
I just don't know that that sort of anticorruption
backlash is as likely to take hold in the
United States given the sort of partisan environment
in which it would have to, we'd have
to operate.
Yeah. I mean this is, this is the real Kryptonite
of American democracy is hyperpolarization
because it destroys accountability. And so
things that normally would command, you know,
bipartisan support or would immediately be
rejected by massive bipartisan majorities
are now splitting along partisan lines. Right?
I mean, you have, one of the examples of this
that I thought it was particularly horrifying
was it's now largely forgotten because of
that scandal overload I talked about before.
But Trump stood on the, on the stage with
Greg g and fourth, the Republican congressman
from Montana last year before the election
and endorsed him. Not In spite of the fact
that because of the fact that you violently
assaulted or reporter, I mean, he was literally
arrested and convicted of physical assault
of a journalist and Trump didn't just endorse
him, but then playfully mocked the body slamming
he did as a journalist, which broke his glasses.
[inaudible]
such force. And it's like old news now, right?
So the idea that that would only split along
partisan lines doesn't bode well for all the
other aspects of reform that happened. For
example, after the Watergate scandal, there
was bipartisan support for reform of government
and it actually ushered in a lot of clean
government initiatives that were useful in
rebuilding trust in American democracy and
American government. And I'm worried that
that won't happen after the Trump years because
republicans who have drank the Koolaid of
Trumpism are just going to say we actually
liked it. We don't think he was corrupt. We
don't think that any of this behavior was
unacceptable. Therefore, we're going to block
any initiatives that try to make sure that
it doesn't happen again. And so that's where,
you know, my pessimistic streak really kicks
in is when I think, you know, are we really
going to come to our senses? I like to believe
that there's going to be this moment where
a light bulb goes off and people say, oh no,
you know, we were blind to these abuses. But
with hyper partisanship and hyperpolarization,
it may not happen.
It may not. And we will certainly have a lot
to contend with if that's the case. We've
been speaking with Brian Class who's an assistant
professor of global politics at University
College London. Check out the new podcast
series, which he hosts
power corrupt. Brian always so great to talk
to you. Make some other credit.